de Rio 2016 voilà la Voix est Libre
continue seconde partie Éric SIO est
avec Christian Paul le député PS de la
Nièvre effectivement lise merci député
de la Nièvre et premier signataire de la
motion B en vue du congrès du PS à
Poitier au début du mois de juin on a
parlé du plan République on a parlé de
l'Europe un mot quand même sur ce que
vous voulez fonder c'est parmi vos cinq
combats
l'écosocialisme c'est quoi c'est sans
les écologistes
déjà ça ça consiste aussi à dire que
aujourd'hui tous les Français doivent se
préoccuper de de l'avenir de la planète
évidemment parce que nous en sommes tous
comptable chacun là où il est dans dans
son mode de vie dans son mode de
consommation c'est l'idée aussi que
personne n'a le monopole des questions
écologique et c'est aussi l'idée que ça
demande beaucoup de de débat collectif
ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure sur le sur
le Morvent et sur la l'enraésinement du
Morvent c'est c'est une question sur
lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé à la fois
avec la charte forestière du parc du
Morvent et puis aussi dans tous ces
débats qui entourit les activités
industriel autour de la forêt je pense
que nous n'avons pas trouvé le les bons
compromis à ce moment-là et que d'un
côté il y a une une tentation
effectivement du du toute industrie et
de l'autre côté il y a une tentation qui
est de d'évacuer complètement la
préoccupation économique donc c'est
compromis ça fait voilà donc c'est
peut-être ça l'écosocialisme c'est
trouver les les bons compromis pour
l'intérêt général à la fois pour
l'écologie sur un territoire euh ou plus
largement on le verra dans quelques mois
avec le grand rendez-vous mondial sur le
réchauffement climatique à Paris et puis
en même temps trouver aussi des façon de
développer une économie durable voilà ce
ce sont des enjeux essentiels et euh euh
c'est vrai que quand on est dans la dans
l'urgence comme peut l'être un
gouvernement qui veut tout de suite des
résultat euh il faut qu'il y ait aussi
ça peut être le rôle des partis
politiques en tout cas je souhaite que
le Parti socialiste s investit davantage
d'avoir peut-être en matière de de débat
des idées sur cette question là de
recherche des compromis un coup d'avance
le gouvernement il est dans la gestion
quotidienne les partis politiques le
mien il peut avoir sur ces questions
écologiques aussi peut-être la la
possibilité davantage de d'animer le
débat et d'avoir de d'inventer les
compromis pour aujourd'hui et demain
alors on parlait des écologistes il y
avait une question je pense qu'on va la
revoir sur Twitter est-ce que si jamais
vous êtes majoritaire hein au Congrès du
PS enlevez-le jamais si nous avons une
nouvelle majorité au si vous avez une
nouvelle majorité euh est-ce que vous
allez travailler à une nouvelle majorité
au plan national et un nouveau
gouvernement alors ce n'est pas le
Congrès du Parti socialiste ce n'est pas
un référendum pour contre le
gouvernement c'est un moment où nous
souhaitons confronter des idées et et je
l'espère à la sortie faire évoluer la
politique qui est menée pour qu'elle
soit plus en d'abord en phase avec nos
engagements 2012 ceux qui ont été
pas assez mis en œuvre et puis aussi
qu'on invente des politiques nouvelles
parce que le le monde bouge on le voit
bien donc il faut arriver à redonner au
Parti socialiste de l'inventivité et
puis de de la stabilité mais dans la
clarté des idées pas dans l'habileté les
ambiguïés je je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
ensuite nous avons une deuxième mission
et le président de la République qui est
également attentif c'est que on ne
termine pas ce ce quinquena avec une
majorité complète rétréci où il n'y
aurait plus que quelques socialistes
donc il faut évidemment dialoguer avec
avec toute la gauche euh en 2012 il y a
une une grande majorité de gauche qui a
accompagé l'élection de de Ben avec tous
ceux qui sont prêts à le faire et il
faut aussi sans doute avoir des
politiques qui puissent être accepbles
plus largement parce que en 2012 il y a
eu ce que j'appelle la grande gauche qui
s'est retrouvé autour de François
Hollande et ça allait très loin pas
seulement les socialistes évidemment il
n'auraient jamais été élu donc si on on
on souhaite que la gauche soit au 2uxème
tour de l'élection présidentielle c'est
pas de l'électoralisme c'est pour
empêcher tout simplement qu'on ait une
une expérience dramatique avec l'extrême
droite ou le retour de Nicolas Sarkozi
avec ce que ça veut dire de de
persistance dans dans les erreurs
aujourd'hui la la la la droite demande
de réduire de 150 milliards le budget
des services publics moi je sais ce que
ça veut dire en Bourgogne et dans la
Nièvre pour les hôpitaux pour les écoles
pour la sécurité pour les transports je
je vois je visualise très bien ce que
produirait le le retour Nicolas Sarkozi
c'est pour ça que je n'entends pas gêner
une seconde le le travail du
gouvernement et et de François alon je
pense simplement qu'il faut l'orienté et
il faut réussir on réussira pas sans
tenir nos engagements les Français nous
attendent ils n'ont pas changé depuis
2012 les Français c'était il y a 3 ans
c'était pas il y a un siècle donc ils
savent très bien sur quel terrain ils
nous attendent l'emploi la justice
sociale les territoires la jeunesse et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut remettre
évidemment le l'ouvrage sur le métier
alors vous avez accepté l'hypothèse dans
le cas où vous serez majoritaire il y a
aussi l'hypothèse inverse qui est souvé
par Pierre si votre motion n'est pas
majoritaire au Congrès donc quelle sera
votre ligne pour sauver le PS et la
politique actuelle
mais moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le
Parti socialiste n'explose pas je
souhaite qu'il soit réuni à à l'issue de
son congrès mais certains voudrai qu'il
soit dans l'unité silencieuse dans la
dans la discipline des mots avant même
que le débat ait lieu pour ça que je
pense que là pendant quelques semaines
nous prenons le temps d'une respiration
c'est ça la démocratie nous prenons le
temps d'un débat vivant le Congrès n'est
pas écrit d'avance il y a pas une
majorité qui serait de droit divin au
sein du Parti socialiste il y a au
contraire aujourd'hui besoin d'une
nouvelle majorité et à l'issue de ce
congrès c'est vrai il faut arriver à ce
à ce que chacun puisse agir utilement si
nous avons une nouvelle majorité ce que
je souhaite je suis prêt à en assumer
l'animation et à faire bouger les choses
dans un dialogue d'ailleurs respectueux
et fécond avec le président de la
République si nous n'avions pas de
majorité je vous place pas vous le
comprenez dans dans cette hypothèse là
et bien nous continuerons à porter des
idées nous le ferons encore une fois
dans le respect des règles du Parti
socialiste mais encore une fois il est
essentiel que ce que nous incarnons
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons défendu
avec je crois beaucoup de de volonté
peut-être de courage aussi je je le dis
ainsi depuis 1 an puisse trouver sa
place au sein du Parti socialiste et et
que on ne se retrouve pas dans une
situation si fréquente surous la 5e
République où la
discipline des partis l'emporte sur les
idées l'imagination et la volonté d'agir
h en tout cas le prochain secrétaire
premier Premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste ce sera soit vous soit
Jean-Christophe kambadis he parce que
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler quand même
aux téléspectateurs comment ça se passe
il y a un vote des militants le 21 mai
donc là on il y a en effet deux votes
c'est c'est assez simple il y a deux
votes il y a deux votes il y en a le 21
mai comme avant on vote pour donc
j'invite vraiment tous les militants
socialistes à venir voter ce jour-là
c'est vraiment l'occasion qu'ils ont
avec leur bulletin de vote de de prendre
position clairement donc le 21 mai c'est
un vote sur les textes donc sur les
proposition et le 28 mai c'est un vote
pour désigner le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste qui aura en charge en
tout cas c'est l'idée que je m'en fais
de revitaliser ce parti qui s'est
endormi dans dans dans son siège de la
rue de Solferino là depuis 3 ans et
qu'il faut vraiment réveiller et c'est
un vote donc qui départagera les
premiers signataires des deux textes
arrivés en tête le au premier tour donc
a priori soit vous soit Jean-Christophe
cambadellis et vous vous êtes bien bien
sûr favorable à un changement de premier
secrétaire je suis favorable à ce que le
Parti socialiste puisse retrouver tout
son rôle inspirer la politique du
gouvernement pas la dictter dans le
détail mais l'inspirer réellement donner
le donner le le cap et également
garantir le respect des engagements que
nous avons pris devant les Français en
2012 François Hollande a été élu en 2012
j'ai été élu comme la majorité des
députés quelques semaines après nous
avons pris des engagements précis il
faut y revenir ces engagements ne sont
pas archaïque ils ne sont pas à mettre
mais quand on regarde le bilan il y en a
il y a les de tiers sont tenus quand
même de ces promesses vous savez ce que
me disait là encore des des jeunes que
je voyais il y a quelques jours c'est
important d'aller à la rencontre de la
jeunesse parce qu'il y a un discours de
vérité toutes les générations on leur
parle de vérité mais les jeunes le
disent parfois de façon plus plus crue
disait mais on fait des réformes qui ne
vont pas jusqu'au bout la réforme
bancaire par exemple oui il y a eu une
réforme bancaire mais elle n'a pas
réduit le poids des banques sur
l'économie et moi je je demande c'est un
nos souhaits dans dans le débat actuel
qu'il y ait une seconde loi bancaire
vous savez aujourd'hui il y a une grande
proportion des projets projets des
entreprises création développement
transmission projet des jeunes qui
veulent créer leur activité pas c'est
parfois 30000 € 20000 € qui sont
demandés il y a une quantité importante
de projets qui ne sont pas acceptés
comment on redonne une responsabilité
des banques sur les territoires où elles
se trouvent comment on on peut avoir une
notation de l'activité des banques faire
la transparence sur cela les banques
prélèvent l'épargne sur nos territoires
beaucoup de projets ne sont pas soutenus
comment on peut faire la lumière sur
cela voilà ce que je voudrais trouver
dans dans une nouvelle loi bancaire pour
revenir à la politique politicienne
entre guillemets même si c'est très
important euh si vous êtes le prochain
Premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
est-ce que vous serez favorable à
organiser des primaires même si François
Hollande est de nouveaux candidats la
décision sur les primaires se prendra en
2016 au vu de la situation les primaires
aujourd'hui sont dans nos statuts donc
on peut pas les balayer d'un revers
deain comme certains le font ça serait
ça serait se moquer des militants
socialistes qui ont voulu ces primaires
quand Martin auri était premier
secrétaireés bien sûr que c'est délicat
et c'est pour ça que c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'on en décide nous avons
la possibilité de faire ce choix
collectivement vous savez François hand
a dit les choses dans un esprit de
responsabilité que je veux souligner il
a dit si nous n'avons pas réussi sur le
terrain économique c'est-à-dire sur la
question de l'emploi et du CH
il a dit lui-même que il ne serait pas
en situation s'il est pas en situation
il faudra évidemment faire des primaires
s'il est en situation ça prend
évidemment une tournure différente et
c'est à ce moment-là dans un an que nous
pourrons juger de la de la possibilité
et de l'opportunité de ces Prim donc je
ne suis pas un hayatola des des
primaires je crois qu'elles sont utiles
je crois qu'elles ont permis à François
hand d'être d'être élu et donc nous
prendrons cette décision collectivement
avec les militants socialistes dans un
an ouais donc en clair c'est si François
Holland ny va pas il y aura des
primaires dans tous les cas ce sera une
décision collective h et élargi à toute
la gauche pardon élargi à toute la GAE
s'il y a des primaires on va pas les les
les ramener à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste après les avoir ouvertes en
2011 je rappelle que ça a été très
apprécié je crois par les Français à tel
point qu'elle s'est copié par par l'UMP
qui s'appelle encore l'UMP avant de
changer de nom ou ce que vous n'aimez
pas beaucoup d'ailleurs pardon ce que
vous n'aimez pas beaucoup ben je trouve
que la République est un bien commun et
que beaucoup de de français de droite et
de gauche sont battus pour la défendre
et sont retourver et cet après-midi dans
le Morvent nous allons inaugurer les
chemins de mémoire c'est-à-dire rendre
hommage au résistant du Morvent il se
battait pour la liberté pour la
République face à l'occupant allemand et
bien ils étaient de droite et de gauche
et on va reparler ce personne n le
monopole de la République on en parlera
ce soir dans le journal régional
d'ailleurs mais je voulais aussi rendre
hommage à à à cette mémoire des
résistants du Morvent merci de m'avoir
permis de le faire B merci en tout cas à
vous d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous pouvez revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet
bourgogne.france3.fr la semaine
prochaine nous reparlerons de la fusion
des régions Bourgogne franchecté au
cours d'une émission spéciale premier
débat politique consacré au régional de
décembre avec la participation de
candidats déjà déclaré ce sera dès 11h
samedi prochain dans un instant c'est le
12 13 qui se poursuit pour le
développement de l'actualité nationale
et internationale très bel après-midi à
tous merci encore
merci